hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the third part of Plato's dialogue
the gorgeous where Socrates is engaging
in discussion with calacles whose house
the conversation is taking place at and
we're gorgeous and polis are calacles
guests there's a back and forth
discussion and then calculus actually
criticizes Socrates for engaging in
philosophy far longer than a grown man
should you know philosophy something
that's good for your Early Education but
you should leave it behind and take on
the sort of interests and desires and
occupations of a real man and Socrates
is not doing that and then Socrates
brings in this very interesting
discussion where he is admittedly being
rather ironic or at least let's say
hopeful about this this guy calacles who
he's engaging in in discussion with and
he tells calculus that he considers him
a godsend that literally he uh got
something from Hermes by happening to be
there and happening to get involved in
this discussion it's uh the word is uh
for sort of like a fortunate accident
you know in a verbal form that's being
used there in the Greek and so why is
this such a great thing he says well you
know if my soul were made of gold don't
you think I would be delighted to find
one of those stones wherewith they test
gold the best of these Stones which I
could apply to so there's this analogy
to testing for gold in the soul there's
some sort of procedure some sort of body
of knowledge for figuring out whether
something is genuinely gold genuinely
valuable or whether it's just a
facsimile a fake something that looks
like old but actually isn't and one of
the terms that gets used here quite a
lot is the word for agreement here in
the optative
homologue sayin but it's also used
verbally in other cases and the idea
here is of Correspondence or you know
being on the same page we could say and
so Socrates is saying listen if I can
find things where you actually agree
with me then I know I'm on the right
path because you obviously are somebody
who can in fact figure out who's right
or wrong who's got things correct and
who has things mixed up in their soul
and so he says you know if we can have a
an agreement that my soul is well
nurtured are well raised well brought up
tetherupay right and the word that's
used before that is Carlos so nobly uh
in touch with the higher values the
better things that I have had not just
my body nurtured but my soul has been
nurtured if you can agree to that
uh then no further testing would
actually be required because you're that
stone you're a good tester and he goes
on and he says that
you know we can test
and the word here
is a very interesting one because it can
also mean to put to the torture it can
mean all sorts of things this is testing
in a rigorous way that could actually be
somewhat uh painful or deleterious to
the thing being tested so he says I'm
convinced if you agree with the opinions
held by my soul we'll have attained the
actual truth
for I observe that anyone who is able to
adequately test a human soul right
whether that Soul now the translation
here is live what good or evil or well
or wrongly in the Greek it's just
whether Souls live rightly orthos
whether they live rightly or not so it
could be you know living wrongly and the
idea is that somebody can in fact be the
Tester the assayer of souls to determine
whether they are living in the right way
or not well somebody like that would
have to have certain qualifications
this isn't the only place of course
where Socrates talks about that in The
Credo it's also mentioned somebody
having you know knowledge of what's just
and unjust what's uh good and bad what
is beautiful and what is ugly and
knowledge is in fact going to be one of
the three qualities or you could say if
you want to the three criteria of the
human being who is fit to judge
accurately The Souls of other human
beings not that other people don't judge
each other constantly but here we're
talking about who can actually judge
correctly who can come to the right
verdicts and so Socrates says that by my
observation there's three things that
are needed in order to judge these
things rightly one of them is knowledge
a piece to me you got to actually know
what the hell you're doing you've got to
understand human Souls human Affairs you
actually to know what is good and what
is bad right so this kind of overlaps
with what he was saying in The Credo and
in other places as well you don't just
need to have like a gut sense or
Intuition or something like that you
need to actually know what the hell
you're talking about
but then that's not enough knowledge is
great but there's some other qualities
that are just as important and one of
these is what in ancient Greek is called
unoia literally so Noya is coming from
noose mind you know and you is is good
or well so being well disposed to a
another person having good will towards
them wanting what is best for them
wanting them not to suffer or encounter
or be destroyed by evil and so that's
really important as well and then
there's a third thing that Socrates
tells us is really important and this is
something that the Greeks at least some
of the Greeks did in fact value and talk
about quite a bit
frankness or freedom is another way of
translating it of speech parasia being
able to say what's on your mind that's
the freedom of speech aspect but being
disposed to actually tell people what
you think not to conceal not to hide not
to be to translate another term not to
be bashful or embarrassed to come right
out and say what you think to be
straightforward right we often say so a
person who wants to test whether other
people's souls are in good condition or
not whether they've been raised properly
they have to have all three of these
qualities why because it's an
interpersonal engagement and he says
calacles you've got these and then
there's a long and interesting
discussion about why that's the case so
he says I encounter a lot of people who
can't test me because they're not wise
like you so that's one thing that
eliminates people right off the bat if
you're just an ordinary person you don't
have any any wisdom or knowledge you're
not going to be a good judge even if
you're using somebody else's techniques
or what what your culture has given you
and you know he says gorgeous or not
gorgeous calculus I know that you
actually have received a good education
a lot of Athenians would agree to that
now the is Socrates being ironic here
yes he is because he doesn't think that
the education that a lot of Athenians
have gotten is actually one that
produces knowledge let's put that aside
though
let's say the calculus actually does
have knowledge that he is wise does he
have good will to Socrates he just said
mean stuff to Socrates a minute ago so
he might say well he doesn't seem to
have good will to Socrates but but
Socrates says you actually do
there are others who are wise
but unwilling to tell the truth because
they don't care for me as you do our two
guests here gorgeous and polish while
they're wise men and friends of mine
right they qualify for that you do too
how do I know uh that you are actually
well disposed to me you make the same
argument about don't study philosophy
well into adulthood to other people
you're being consistent in what it is
that you're telling them I think that
you care for them you're giving me the
same advice therefore you must care for
me you're not doing it just to be mean
you're not doing it to put me down
you're not doing it to shut me up you're
doing it because you you really like me
you care about me and you want the best
for me again me might be a little ironic
in that as well
frankness of speech calacles definitely
has that and here's where Socrates says
something interesting so gorgeous and
polis these guests they are
knowledgeable they have a good will to
me but they're more deficient than they
should be in outspokenness and somewhat
to bashful how could it be otherwise
when their bashfulness is so great that
out of sheer timidity each of them
Ventures to contradict himself in the
event in the presence of many people and
about matters of supreme importance but
that's not you calacles how do I know
that he says
um it's it's clear that you are inclined
to be frank and not bashful why be by
your own statement and confirmed in the
speech you made a short time ago you
know you are willing to call me out on
what you think I'm doing wrong you're
not going to hold back so clearly you
actually have the Frank of speech that's
needed in order for knowledge to be put
into effect and Goodwill to be displayed
calacles speaks his mind unlike the
other two now we're finally getting to
the Bedrock you could say and so
Socrates says again he may not really
mean this completely but he's he's sort
of sketching what it would be like for
somebody an imaginary interlocutor who
really was the tester of souls who could
tell us whether we're living rightly or
wrongly I've got our heads on straight
or or crookedly whether we're you know
well-formed or badly formed they would
need to have these things and he is
saying I'm so lucky that I did find you
because now you can tell me whether I've
got things right or not whether you
agree with me or not so these are some
uh really interesting observations here
calacles if you read the dialogue
doesn't really live up to these other
than the frankness of speech I don't
think that you can say he is truly well
motivated in terms of Goodwill he
clearly doesn't know what he's talking
about when it comes to some important
matters although he does have some
knowledge of other things and so he's
not the genuine tester but this is
sketching out what somebody who would be
a great interlocker to have somebody who
would benefit us what it is that they
would look like what characteristics
they would have to have and to display
to their fellow interlocutors